[Music]
evening how's everyone doing tonight and
yes thank you very much pirates for
filling in it's greatly appreciated is
there such a thing as a mature and
responsible adult they claim there is I
don't think I believe it ah got my water
good on you uh nice shirt a man full of
hoodie
uh I'm rather fond of this I should wear
it more than I do
I don't wear it all that often homemade
brownies milk bliss ha ha ha
good choice is all around so yeah I
don't have like a particularly major
point to talk about in terms of having
the subject be superheroes just kind of
us bit on my hands lately um I figure
hey well you know given that oftentimes
topics on this thing jump from like
Doctor Who to superheroes to the lgbtq+
topic and not that I'll like shy away
from it if questions come up but like
let's try and funnel it down see what we
can do my 17 year old is going as
spider-man and is his girlfriend is
going to be MJ nice uh-huh my kiddos
going is Pikachu and I may have been
conned into agreeing to go as ash I got
here late I don't know the rules there
aren't a ton okay just don't be a jerk
and you'll be fine have you seen Jo ki
it happens I have a review up that's
it's always weird like it's one thing if
they're asking me if I've seen something
that that like was a video ages ago and
like way back in cuz they've got over a
thousand videos on this dang thing but
like
like a week ago I put that review up
yeah I've seen it the things we do for
our kids yeah yeah that's true
you care to speak it you you could be a
chew the problem is there I don't think
I could find a custom of my size and I
am NOT crafty so I am making it that
that is a cute idea though for me to be
the evolution Kevin Feige is the new CCO
for all of Marvel yeah I was gonna come
to that eventually but you know what we
can we can kick off with that one
so yes Kevin Feige previously only head
of the Marvel films has basically been
made the head of all things Marvel now
this doesn't mean that he's going to be
directly putting his hand or his fingers
and do all the other departments i
severely doubt that it just means that
now all the other departments
except for publishing and marketing and
merchandising which is still under Ike
Perlmutter but all the creative
departments answer to him so the head of
Marvel Comics but I think is still Joe
Quesada now answers to him he used to
have to answer to Perlmutter the folks
the the Marvel animations now answers
directly to him Marvel TV answers
directly to him basically I think I
think Disney ISM has very much seen this
guy knows what he's doing a heck of a
lot better than I promoter does if you
don't know the whole history about about
I promotors running of marble look the I
promoter is in many ways the O God why
why don't I forget his name all of a
sudden the guy who headed Disney before
the before the camera guy ah Eisner
there we go
I pro mutters very much the Michael is
very much to marvel with Michael Eisner
is to Disney the company would not exist
if he had not come in
helped run it why after a while like he
really needs somebody really needed to
take his hands off the thing and it
seems like they are now more or less
done doing that he still technically
holds a position but he's completely out
of the creative end of things which to
my mind is a good thing I were to go as
a shy be asked from the evil dead hahaha
I wish I was craft you'll be wonderful
Sanderson I have friends who keep
talking about doing the Sanderson
sisters see what do you think about the
plan crossover for venom and MCU Spidey
that's where both movie series are
building entirely well I mean we've
known that's what Sony's wanted forever
it was just Marvel didn't want to do it
because with the way the deal had worked
before if Sony had put venom into the
spider-man movie that meant Marvel would
have been in deciding how venom gets
handled and Sony didn't want them to do
that because they wanted to be able to
do their own thing with venom and given
that they have now done their own thing
with venom you know that there was a big
question when venom looked like it was
going to be rated R Marvel wanted
nothing to do with it they didn't want
it touching Spidey but given that they
dialed that back I'm not shocked to see
this kind of headed that direction I
figured that was a matter of time
honestly but if he's been murdered by
crystal meth tweakers and then we're
luck what did I miss a topic jump uh
nice jacket thank you I'm crafty but I
have absolutely no experience making
clothes beyond crocheting hats and
scarves and such seems we have matching
nail polish today oh yeah I'm rather
fond of this one I'll give you a better
look at that hey I gotta get to catch
the light because it's it's it's dark
purple but it's also got like like
sparkles in it
that's got a little better their
favorite Batman an arguable best Batman
I mean I have an odd soft spot for and
I'm gonna be real specific about this
peter weller as Dark Knight Returns
Batman I don't want to go so far as a
Dark Knight Returns Batman in general is
my favorite Batman but his performance
really good that said if we're talking
broadly best bet best Batman is Kevin
Conroy I mean just like Mark Hamill is
best Joker I mean they just did that
that is a fact of the universe that's
like the basic principles of physics you
you can base everything else around that
but that fact does not change
did you see the Catwoman news yes zoe
kravitz is that confirmed yet cuz last I
said that was being reported um and like
was supposedly verified but like hadn't
been officially announced yet did I miss
an official announcement or are we still
in the yeah we're pretty sure but it's
not confirmed stage but yes I did hear
um I'll be really curious how many
jackasses try to go oh they're making
Catwoman black and like completely
ignoring the fact that Eartha Kitt
played Catwoman in the friggin 60s God's
sake do you have any plans to see or
review El Camino um I have seen it I'm
not gonna review it cuz I actually don't
have that many thoughts on it but I did
see it hold on let me just check a
couple things Catwoman's confirmed oh
cool
that works I was quoting a line from The
Hangover for the record oh okay well
that's the brahmic honor I haven't seen
the hangover since like the year it came
out um so that's why I missed that so
yeah I'll touch on El Camino since it
was brought up um overall it was a
decent coda to Breaking Bad because you
know after all he'd been through just
kind of deserved about his happy and
ending as he was capable of getting but
also given the nature of Breaking Bad
as a narrative and the kind of stain
Walter White left on the world it's
fitting that he had to work a little bit
harder from where we last excuse me from
where we last saw him to get to have an
actual ending because kind of what
happened to him at the end and wasn't
properly an ending it's nice to get
closure on that um and it was well made
I don't really have much to say beyond
that though I mean it was it was good
cool didn't blow me away but you know it
was a little bit more Breaking Bad it
was fine it's just me or does the shot
look better today than in other life
strains yeah I actually don't know
what's going on there I'm thinking the
same thing that like I don't know it's
less it's the same phone so I don't know
why it's behaving better today I wonder
if it's because I'm wearing something
with so much white and that the that the
white balance on the on the phone is not
being a jerk
I loved El Camino it was good epilogue
for this epilogues are good is a good
word for it
you are super hero super youtuber your
superpower is your intellect in kindness
ah Thank You Donna I'm not sure that
either of those I have it a super level
but I do I do my best with a lot of God
please cover El Camino because I'm not
watching a review by a nostalgia critic
well I mean the reason I don't plan to
do um a video is because I don't have
enough thoughts to fill a video it was
good it was more Breaking Bad Breaking
Bad was good I mean good you're not
gonna get a lot out of it if you didn't
watch the show I mean you can probably
follow it if you haven't watched the
show it gives you enough to work as a
narrative but you're not gonna have a
ton of investment if you didn't watch
the show are you a fan of Rami Malek I
haven't seen him in that much I mean I
saw him in I did I did two episodes of
mr. robot for because I was commissioned
to I've seen him in Bohemian Rhapsody I
mean he was good in both of those I'm
sigh I haven't played but I've seen
Let's Plays of until dawn and he was
fine in that he was a little bit campy
but like so is everybody okay the thing
is like I'm at a point where I'm not
sure there's that many actors who I'd go
like I'm a fan of that actor I'm usually
a fan of a specific performance it's
pretty rare these days for me to go out
that I'm just a fan of an actor it
doesn't really happen too much for me
these days yeah I just might have
outgrown the concept have you seen the
supervillain bold it's also superhero
bold but I haven't seen that one
nope I am not familiar did you have any
thoughts on the birds of prey trailer
and just the film overall um if then
we're gonna make a birds-of-prey film I
wish they made a birds-of-prey film and
not Harley Quinn featuring some people
that we swear are the birds of prey but
you know I said that before there
anybody in particular you'd like his
Batman I would say Anson mount he'd make
a phenomenal Bruce and would be a great
Batman Christopher Pike in Star Trek
discovery Oh wasn't he um
wasn't he Black Bolt in Inhumans also
have you seen the Contra points video on
opulence I've started it I haven't
finished it yet I haven't really been in
the mood um like I'm really bad person
s4 fan casting like who would you want
to play X calculate I don't know my
brain doesn't work like that have you
ever heard of the gone series by Michael
Grant it's a really cool series that
deals with superpowers so I was
wondering your opinion on the series if
you've read it I am not familiar with
either that series or that writer
unfortunately yes he was yeah I thought
like you said that name you said answer
my like I know I know not only have I
seen that name before
I've said it before I've said that name
why would I have said that name and I
had to backtrack cuz I had to drink to
get through the premiere pilot thing of
the Inhumans so props on me for
remembering that did you watch raising
Deon I have not one of my co-workers
brought that up my mother is making
apple crisp would you care for her piece
a la mode
um what huh see I'm in Vermont so I
would take my apple crisp warmed up with
a slice of cheddar cheese cuz that's how
we do if you could form an Avengers team
out of your favorite youtubers who would
you pick to fight ben shapiro
okay um so let me think here so if I
were to if I were to assemble an
Avengers team out of youtubers and like
I'm not gonna go into full detail on
this but let's just imagine superpowers
that would relate in some way to the
kinds of YouTube stuff that they do we
get contra points in there we have
philosophy tube in there
[Music]
could have Jeremy Jones as the as the
hot head of the group Lindsey Ellis
could be the the tactician well I I mean
I'm just I'm just gonna start listing
like youtubers that I subscribe to but
those are off the top ahead we should
call your live stream water that's not
water dark water and humans comic is
interesting and fun two things the show
wasn't I had a friend who lent me a
volume of Inhumans stuff I got through
about a couple of issues of it I'm it
wasn't bad but I didn't realize like
this is just not for me
um thoughts on Robert Downey jr.
returning for the Black Widow movie also
his Doctor Dolittle movie I mean I won't
have opinions on his Black Widow part
until I see it and know exactly the
context and the Doctor Dolittle movie
it's gonna flop it's not gonna make its
money back cuz movies with large-scale
animals always cost way to more
off-topic thoughts on the an ox our
kerfuffle I don't know what that is
hmm any recent comics I highly recommend
the recent run of mr. miracle I got my
vol sign dad and ycz I have a number of
friends who really dig mr. miracle I
never really got into his stuff I do
like big Berta though so I could be my
hook in that woman's show haven't seen
it yep
Heath Ledger Joker vs. Thanos who's the
best best cinematic super villain of all
time I don't think you can even compare
those two I mean like I mean you could
as well as but like the kinds of
villains that they are that is a matter
of preference just because like what
they're doing and how they go about it
is so completely different they're
almost antithetical excuse me to each
other that you know I just wouldn't
think to compare them
was the best avenger and why is it Steve
Rogers last Captain America um I mean
because he's because that's America's
ass what more do you need
if you're looking for a highly
underrated work of animation I will
recommend in the 1983 movie twice upon
the time you are not the first one to
recommend that to me I've had a number
of people recommend that it's been a
little while since I've tried to look
for it lad like look I hadn't recommend
it to me years ago but I couldn't find
it
I haven't looked again lately so I don't
know if it's popped up streaming or
rentable digitally anywhere since the
last time I checked if you could pick
one superpower what would it pick
shape-shifting always in forever that's
that that will always be my answer in
light of your recent Christopher
Eccleston video do you eat ah
got away from me do you did you know
he's coming to calibrate one in 2020 I
did know I'll be a growl afraid one two
I don't think I can afford the extra
money to get like a photo op with them
or anything but um I'm gonna be there
too so that'll be cool let's see have
you seen the boys from Amazon I have not
I'm not a huge fan of Garth Ennis who
wrote the original comics so it's not
exactly high on my list I'm watching
Gotham partially on your recommendation
I'm part way through season three and
I'm enjoying the hell out of it thanks
that is good to hear because first
season is a bit tough because the first
season is the most normal but man
Gotham's fun it's and I accept that it's
not for everybody but if you can tune
into the wavelength of that insanity oh
god it's fun have you ever been to
Wisconsin I have not I dunno know that
Vermont she's consistently beats
Wisconsin cheese so I can be salty
have you finished properly morning your
fix beard yet no no no amount of time is
going to truly heal the wound of your
achieving his beard for people who don't
know that is a reference to my favorite
role-playing podcast improvised weapons
in which the the dwarf character of the
artifact in an attempt to go incognito
recently shaved his beard and a moment
of silence please free our Vic's beard
hmm preferred superpower flying that's a
good one any superhero movies you'd love
you love that everyone else hates I'm
talking like Green Lantern or Catwoman
levels here um not that I love I
actually kind of had fun with Elektra
and I'm a bit of a of an apologist for
the daredevil film but I don't love them
I mean heck I'm a bit of an apologist
for Batman Forever
oh there's one there's one that I like
that it seems to finally be building a
little bit of recognition like cult
level but Punisher war zone man like I
get I get why critics hated it I even
get why it flopped I get my mainstream
audiences didn't take to it but the fact
that comic fans crap on Punisher war
zone ticks me off actually the Thomas
Jane Punisher a lot better than people
say it was as well the war zone was by
far the best out of the out of the
Punisher takes don't you dare take a
name of Wisconsin dairy in vain I didn't
take it in vain I challenged it but
there is a difference favorite D&D story
you mean like novels are run on I have a
read a lot not lately anyways I used to
oh man this is going back I used to read
some of the Forgotten Realms stuff I
used to read RA Salvatore's
sub the Drizzt Do'Urden books I read
those for a while I'm thinking of seeing
violence Voyager on your recommendation
that's a trip I mean like if you can if
you're up for something unusual and a
bit freaky it'll fill that boy but that
movie is a trip superhero team-up you
would love to see can be DC Marvel or
combo of the two huh um okay this is
gonna sound weird unless you've read any
of the comics where they run into each
other but um give me Howard the dark and
she-hulk thoughts on spicy brown mustard
I am NOT a mustard fan in any variety I
like softened on it a little over the
years but it's never something I'd
request what states have you visited
okay let me think um what do you think
of black hole of the black hole that
shut down fortnight I don't have any
opinion on anything for tonight
so okay what states have you visited
well okay Vermont New Hampshire Maine
Massachusetts New York Connecticut Rhode
Island Virginia Florida Indiana
California Oregon think that's it yeah
most of the middle of the country I have
skipped over a favorite personal D&D
story assuming you've played um I don't
know man I just kind of like um alas the
ad campaign ru hey playboy I'm trying to
think of there's a short version of this
cuz this was DM by my friend Paul which
means it's weird and it's difficult to
explain so okay so I'm not gonna give
you the context to how I got into this
issue
but I was trying to do a mercy kill on a
dragon by getting into his mouth and
stabbing its brain from up inside its
mouth and in and after doing that and
trying to get out of the things mouth I
lost a leg and I was playing I was
playing a 1/2 work barbarian and we
ended up getting at the next leg of our
quest from a deity who granted me a new
leg except it was an elf's leg so I had
this big hulking half-orc character with
this one
slender yo delicate elf leg that I did
actually like peek through a curtain to
entice a guard at one point that was
good times
Jubilees the best x-man just saying
Steven I'm gonna disagree but I'm gonna
go in the same sort of template ballpark
and say kitty pryde is the best x-man
sauce on Batman Beyond
honestly I haven't see that many um
episodes of the show I do really like
the return of the Joker movie though I
enjoy that a lot
uh don't think you've ever been asked on
here which is your favorite superhero a
spider-man so I will always come back to
Spidey a friend of mine recommended a
British television film from 1984 called
threads it deserves to be watched for
how it depicts nuclear devastation in
such an immensely realistic way sounds
good also sounds depressing
so um might stick a pin in that III I
tread lightly around heavy depressing
stuff these days I just got a lot on my
plate you know there's only so much I am
prepared to have my entertainment people
on me and I told that one of things
about watching El Camino because
Breaking Bad's a heavy dark
of an existential show so I'm glad it
was only a movie and not like a whole
season because that might have been a
bit much for me with that tone why is
hell-bent ranked the 34th best Doctor
Who episode on IMDB because the IMDB
ratings and rankings are completely
effed in the egg like you cannot trust
those things anymore anything that has
any kind of fan war on it has gotten
review bombed in either direction either
too high or too low or two battling
segments evening each other out
I am d-beam it's a decent place for
information if you're going there for
opinions and reviews it's a disaster
area that's why if he's in the Wonder
Woman movie from 2009 um the the
animated one I'm assuming you mean yeah
I own that it's quite good
ah Kitty's cool damn right Kitty's cool
Kitty's awesome
[Music]
what would your superhero supervillain
name be I don't know I don't whenever I
write I'm very self-conscious about how
cheesy I'm being and given that
superhero or super villain names tend to
be very cheesy I did I think I'd need
somebody else to name me I don't think
I'd ever come up with anything I'm happy
with I think I just have to start doing
either the heroics or the villainy and
let somebody like Jay jonah Jameson
named me across the front page and let
that be it what do you think is the most
underrated superhero movie I mean
probably Punisher war zone like I said
earlier and I mentioned a few others any
tips for writing an lgbtq+ romance novel
um no because
I don't like romance stories very very
rarely I don't write them it might all
work with like one key exception that
I'm um is a lot of work for me to wrap
my head around but um you know I'm not a
person to ask in regards to advice
writing romantic stuff cuz my advice
nine times out of ten is to be don't a
bit of a downer like that have you read
The Masque comic I've never read it
myself I'm familiar with it I know how
frigging brutal that thing is so weird
it was such a like a family-friendly
thing has to be better thing kilgrave I
love Fantastic Four especially 2005 to
2007 yeah that was the Mark Waid run
wasn't it that was good that was good
stuff Dredd is underrated I see I'm not
sure if Dredd is underrated Dredd is
under scene but everyone I know he's
seen it thinks it's great so I do
distinguish between underrated and under
watched to me underrated is things that
people say is bad but is better than
they say under watched just means not
enough people saw it that should have
and I think that's more the case for
Dredd so using personal definitions
you know distinguishing as I do between
underrated and under watched hey I just
got home from seeing the Addams Family
how was that
the trailers really turned me off so I'm
kind of curious what you thought have
you seen the original 60s Batman if so
favorite villain Oh Frank Gorshin
Riddler I'm right I'm right there with
you Gabe yeah
he was the bomb so I'm gonna explain
what happened with Eisner I'm waiting
for my library to get Disney war from
the state I mean at what point eisenerz
run at Disney is a
long thing hang on a second vote
off-topic but I'd like your advice a
friend wants to make a character trans
from the beginning not a realization
I'll explain a bit more I need more than
one message box okay so keep it coming
in I'll get back to you so um I mean
Eisner Disney was in a very bad place at
the tail end of the 80s Eisner was
brought in I think you've been at
Paramount um and he was brought in to
run things and he Eisner is not a
creatives guy he's just not everything
is business but he does understand that
good artistic product is good for
business he did at least get that much
and it was under his tenure and not like
directly because he had Katzenberg
working on the animation studio for a
while before the two of them clashed and
Katz Berg was out but I under eyes
winners tenure you had the Disney
Renaissance you had Disney acquiring ABC
which actually wasn't great for them and
took a while to pan out um but he he
helped build Disney back up cuz in the
ended by the mid 80s it was in him it
was in bad shape um but you know then
under his watch you also got things like
the glut of direct-to-video animated
sequels because they could cash in so
you know eyes room was a mixed bag but
he definitely saved the company
regardless some days you just can't get
rid of a bomb ugh ah such a great line
out of West was great well I'll talk
about under preach I actually I feel
like people are gaining a new appreciate
him for a time what appreciation for
Adam West's Batman which is good have
you ever heard or watch the TV show the
Fosters I have heard of it I have never
watched it as a member of the lgbtq+
community I believe it to be the best
portrayal of such characters and issues
in media that's good to hear it's you
know it's a family drama though which
just isn't my genre I mean that I mean
there's a reason I tend to really push
for these sorts of things to show up in
things like
sci-fi and superhero
and fantasy because that's what I like I
don't want to have to venture into a
genre I don't care about to get
characters that I can relate to but
that's good to hear
yeah I mean good representation is good
a representation whether it's in a genre
I care about her not so that's still a
good thing that's probably not gonna get
me to watch it okay so I'm talking about
The Addams Family I thought it was okay
there was some funny visual jokes but
not huge on the story itself huh that's
a shame any expectations and thoughts on
the new Suicide Squad I'm really not
gonna have any thoughts until I see a
trailer we saw some images some very
bright garish costumes but again until
you see them on screen and know how they
are gonna be lit and everything else
that's it's hard to go off that alone
The Addams Family was kind of cute but
very much for a young audience it was
pretty simple plot wise but I did laugh
out loud at the jokes mostly yeah maybe
that's a streaming sort of thing for me
stay here last week I watched an anime
film from 1985 called night on the
Galactic railroad it's very meta an
ethereal film and ended up becoming one
of my favorites I've never heard of that
one huh I'm like and then I haven't seen
a ton of anime at this point but I've
heard of a fair amount of it that is
that's a new name to me
have you seen sunstate watch the first
episode thought it was very cool and
have not found the time to get back into
it I really do want to watch that show
Julie Newmar or Eartha Kitt I mean
aren't the kids just such a bad ass of a
human being I think I'm always gonna
default in favor of Eartha Kitt the
character is formed I don't feel
comfortable because it feels like
adding it like going um this one will be
gay this one's trans I don't like that
for inclusive characters ok so then this
is John talking about the thing is
friends writing I feel that assigning
that later and changing the character is
not a good way for representing um see I
I'm always a results focused person um I
will grant the certain processes certain
ways of going about these things tend to
lead to certain final results and who
better final results more often than
others but I'm not gonna automatically
say that um basically create basically
writing your characters and then giving
them attributes like being trans or
being gay or being black or being
whatever being a woman you know taking
blanks like characters and adding those
traits I don't think that is
automatically a bad thing provided you
don't just give them those traits and
then think you're done the way to do it
that like that because I think there is
a viable way to do it in that approach
is to write your story so that you know
your narrative you know every characters
function in that plot and then to go
back and deepen the characterization and
if that is the point at which you start
adding things like I character being
trans that's fine but you need to look
very carefully at that characters
function in the story the way that they
behave and figure out how does being
trans affect what they do and how to
behave in I don't just mean lines of
dialogue I mean does the things that
they do in the plot still make sense or
would they make sense more now that I
know this thing about this character if
I adjust them and usually you should so
I think it's fine doing it that way
provided that you actually go down the
rabbit hole of all the implications
because if a character is trans maybe
then discovering it is not part of this
narrative but that's been a part of
their life at some point so maybe it
makes you realize the baggage that care
just gonna have that you can alter their
interact
with other characters or their reaction
to something that goes on in accordance
with the baggage or whatever experiences
they would have had as part of being
trans that weren't part of their
bachelor when you wrote your initial
draft so again you can stamp these
traits on afterwards provided you then
follow through on what that addition
means the trap is writing a bunch of
blank slates just assigning them
character traits like trans queer
changing the gender from man to woman
etc and then just going cool and I have
a diverse cast I'm done that's how you
get tokenism and that doesn't work let's
see you think Marvel will finally honors
farmer Dan promise have an explicitly
gay LGBTQ blue superhero and the
Avengers franchise in films well it's
supposedly happening in eternals and I'm
sure they will eventually anyways but at
this point like I'm not gonna give them
a massive applause I'm gonna give them a
sarcastic golf clap it's like is 20-plus
films at this point like seriously at
this point you know for that but the
same reason that while I enjoy Captain
Marvel is a film I'm not gonna hold this
against the film the fact that it took
them as many movies as it did to do a
female lead one no there's no reason
that it should have taken that long it's
no reason black panthers should have
taken that long
the results were still good I'm happy
they exist but I'm only I'm not gonna
give a ton of praise to the MCU because
they drag their feet on this stuff they
went stay for way longer than they
needed to which is annoying have you
seen dr. Horrible's sing-along blog oh
yeah oh yeah it's fun I like it I don't
I don't love the ending I like I get
what it's going for but how think it
totally works I feel like it's this
overly Melling call
the thing that doesn't feel completely
earned it feels kind of kind of slapped
on if I'm being honest
anyway guardians of the galaxy volume 2
is my favorite Marvel movie mask of the
phantasm of my favorite DC movie solid
choices both who would win in a fight
between Lars from Metallica who lurch
from Addams Family his lords alright
like this big yeah I don't think that
would that would be a long winded fight
why are bisexual males so
underrepresented in media I find them to
be the easiest of the lgbtq+ characters
to write
well for your part um that's probably
partly because you yourself are male so
just you know a male carriage is going
to be easier for you to write then a
female character just on its face so
that's not showing to me that it's easy
for you why are they represented lest ah
because bisexual women are sexy that's
why and there's almost never a story a
reason to have a bisexual male character
like bisexual females and you get a lot
of bisexual female villainous is like a
lot of femme fatale style characters
either are or are implied to be bisexual
because there's an inherent
untrustworthiness to it but again sexy
yeah
Tessa's the only person I trust on queer
rap in the MCU she fought for us she's
my idol Tessa Thompson is a very cool
person no tokens whatsoever that's a
good process thanks I will definitely
implement that process for the story
look for artifacts loss coming to
bookshelves probably never uh I know
that feeling I've started getting some
more beta reader feedback on my book it
is tempting tempting to say you know
dreams of fire coming to a bookstore
near you the the 15th of November okay
last have you seen a red for this dream
I promise Yeah right
how much rick riordan have you read zero
i have not read rick riordan I've had
Magnus chase brought up repeatedly to me
to check out for the lgbtq+
representation but I have not read his
stuff just watch the Rocky Horror
Picture Show because of your review and
love D yes gladly Regina spread the word
your favorite superhero
Laurie sorry my favorite super here is
the terror that flats and the night
let's get dangerous uh
Darkwing Duck was a good time that was
one of those shows that I didn't always
watch um but I did always catch the
opening credits theme go that did like
it a lot did you do a review video for
solo and will you do one for the rise of
Skywalker yes and yes will you be
getting Disney Plus and is it scary how
many things they own and are able to put
up on there also yes and yes uh-huh
I have a lot of nostalgia for guardians
of the galaxy one for a few reasons it
was the first superhero movie I loved
cool first pg-13 movie I saw that's a
milestone made me love sci-fi comedies
ya know I'm solid solid endorsements oh
my god no Rick Riordan I'm sorry I'll
wait a couple years you'll probably have
to
read it in self-defense like the rest of
us finish Dark Crystal Age of resistance
today loved it especially the call back
yeah yes I'm not I'm not gonna quote it
because that's a minor spoiler but yeah
Chamberlain's the best and he plans on
reviewing king of the monsters um as a
formal review uh no I do I have a number
of movies that I missed in theaters that
I need to basically cram before the end
of the year so I can figure out if I'm
we're gonna put them on my top-10
at the end of the year or not that's one
Shazam is one us is another it's
probably a few oh I'm forgetting your
world building and your book is
fantastic Oh God
Thank You Stephen Stephen is one of the
people beta reading the book so uh my
first movie I saw all the way through
was Batman 1989 any thoughts on the
prevalence of children's card games in
popular media
I don't know never thought about it
harry did you watch her name in the
Goblet of Fire have you seen do Patrol I
have not it did look amusingly weird but
I have not gone to it but one of my
favorite movies from the 1960s Butch
Cassidy the Sundance Kid don't suppose
you've seen it have you I have and it is
very good that's a William Goldman
script so that's that's usually good
stuff what's it like for a kid to have
parents who are just friends rather than
in a relationship you and your kids mom
relationship is the norm and in the
culture that's the norm I mean what's it
like for her to have parents like that
I don't know I'd like it's it's her
normal at this point I mean the main
thing is just to be sure that me and her
mother get along and we do
which is you know part of why we're not
together anymore so that we could get
along better because we're we're better
friends and better joint parents than we
were married couple so there you go have
you been watching tight season - I have
not over more anyhow Wampus that was I
got it we need to add that to the drink
questions list cuz that comes up every
now and then thoughts on the cost of
collagen issues with the capitalist
model for higher education
um capitalism should not be part of the
education process Berra said it slow
there and represent Mike my kid got
sorted into Gryffindor and she's like
taking super pride in it now it's been
very interesting if Disney Plus doesn't
put up every film and it is the animated
Canon then what's the point
I mean they're still not putting up song
to the south uh-uh
and I don't even know why they're
bothering to hide that one at this point
don't forget the discord ah thank you
pirates yes I got a pop over there which
cinema which marvel cinematic character
is the greatest movie I mean come on
it's America's ass like why would you
even bother asking me that
did you see Pottermore shutting down I
did not hear that no I was unaware I'm
glad I got I figured out my kids
um house and her her Patronus okay so
I'm just I'm hopping back to the discord
real quick folks so if you hit me up
with questions while I'm over here doing
this I'm gonna miss him so just be aware
um here's an easy question for the topic
is Martin Scorsese write about comic
book movie movies not being cinema
hahaha yes and no
he's right by whatever his personal
definition of cinema is and what I mean
by that is he's using cinema to
basically mean artistically merited film
because there's no on paper definition
that distinguishes cinema from just
being a movie but in his head he has
some distinction as to what elevates
something to the level of cinema and
whatever his personal definition is
comic book movies don't match so I don't
think he's wrong but he's also he's also
using his own personal definition as
part of this statement and given that I
don't know exactly how we need to find
cinema it even if I did I don't know if
I'd agree with it so like it's it's just
a kind of an elitist position I mean it
reminds me more than a little one Roger
Ebert declared that video games can
never be art it's like like I know you I
know you're really attached to art forms
that you know or as you know them but
you're wrong it's kind of where I am on
that what's your take on all the
starpower they're putting into crisis on
Infinite Earths I will it be worth the
fanservice
if most of these are just brief cameos I
think so I mean that's kind of the
nature of mashing up that many
characters anyway they're not all gonna
get spotlighted but they're all gonna be
there that's just kind of fun
fossum zoe kravitz being cast as
Catwoman and Batman I did mention that I
think it's cool
I've liked what I've seen her in so far
that I've seen that was on Kevin Feige
taking over marveled yep talked about
that who's your favorite Avenger okay
that depends on whether I'm talking the
movies or the comics cuz the movies
probably spider-man because I I'm
counting him as an Avenger and in the
comics is gonna be weird my god he's
just so much fun
Hercules Hercules has the personality
that movie Thor had has at times so like
in the first Thor movie where Thor has
come and goes this drink I like it
Anala that's a very Hercules moment he
had right there and Hercules is like
that all the time so I should like him a
lot he's a lot of fun so have you seen
the new a stiff movie latest one was 12
I believe yes I did
do you know which livestream started the
of the Daleks mean meme no I don't I
don't know when that started thoughts on
Greta Thornburg power tour that's good
couple more off to discord then I'm then
I'm coming back
what other universe ie Doctor Who could
could you see in a series or show which
both brought together
sorry brought together with either DC or
marvel um oh you know you could mash up
you know what I think would be fun to
mash up with Marvel cosmic and I think
would slot in really well with things
like the guardians of the galaxy and and
things like that
Farscape I think that mashed together
real well favorite scary movie um I
don't know if I could say it's my
favorite scary movie but the scariest
movie I've ever seen 1978 invasion of
the Body Snatchers I still stand by that
[Music]
speculation on the way the doctor
relates to gender do you think things
like gender identities
gelatine Errol a typic a typic ality etc
change for the doctor between
regeneration or is some of that constant
what is necessary for you to buy that
the doctor still the doctor the doctor
has to maintain their moral compass
their same moral values in terms of what
is or is not okay what does or does not
require them to step in and act the way
in which they go about it will vary the
ways in which they will interact with
others will vary their sense of self
clearly varies but that core I think is
really all you need to keep that in that
in the Britishness and that's not
necessarily intrinsic to the doctor as a
character but I think is very much part
of the ident in this show and I don't
think they should ever ditch that top
five who tubers Oh God um I don't know
[Music]
do back fold when ye Doctor Who guide
ace creeper crispy probe there you go
what would your dream collab regardless
of how realistic it would be um Lyndsey
Ellis incredibly unrealistic alright so
I'm back I'm off the discord so I and
forgive me folks I'm not gonna scroll
back up through to catch questions that
I missed so sorry about that
do you think doctor who could fit in the
MCU I mean he could yeah here's what
I'll say I would like to see the doctor
get into an argument with dr. strange
that's about the extent to which I'd
care to see the to mash up the best
Batman costume not actor costume that is
a good question if we're sticking with
live-action um I'm still partial to the
89
I'm being honest it's not the most
practical it just looks good
does it help to do little short projects
for people with a DD to battle inability
to finish projects off topic
um it's helpful for me I can't speak for
anyone else and how they manage their
ADHD but yeah for me that's that's very
helpful should Slytherin house have been
abolished after 1997 that's my house
you're talking about you watch your
mouth I finally find found out who I'm
going to be for Halloween
Rodger Hudson the singer from Supertramp
one of my favorite bands of all time
cool I don't know if anyone's gonna know
who you are but have fun do you have a
slot open for MCU Hogwarts starting with
Liz is a coming suit we well it would be
phase two cuz we did phase one a year
ago um I've been trying to get back to
that forever but you know us us getting
things sorted and getting and you know
between timing and having the motivation
to do it and everything else it just
hasn't happened is it coming soon
I hope so can I promise that no
absolutely not
Slytherin deserves better treatment I
concur I'll admit I did think drink it
was hot even when he was evil well
that's a bad-boy thing that's something
else
thoughts on Neil Gaiman playing the
doctor Ken Neil Gaiman even act I'm not
sure he can he's a very cool guy if you
wanted to base an interpretation of the
doctor on Neil Gaiman that could be good
I don't think he can actually act would
you like to see a Doctor Who episode
where they reference and go back to a
place from an earlier episode and he
actually changes the decision he made
it's only one to try it I'd be
interested to see how that would work
I'm not sure it's something I'd asked
for
are there any two doctors you think
wouldn't make for a particularly
interesting multi doctors story and vice
versa I don't think that the second and
the eleventh doctor would be that
interesting together because they're too
similar does the existence of Slytherin
house just results in kids with negative
personality traits only being exposed to
other kids who will exacerbate them no
stop denigrating my house it's not a
breeding ground for bad influences any
more than any other is it's one of the
things look and this actually this
aggravates me about the way JK Rowling
wrote it and this aggravated me and the
first season of the Dragon Prince there
is this assumption that if someone is a
pragmatist that they lack any kind of
moral compass that they'll just do
whatever gets them the result they want
and that they have no regard for morals
that's not what pragmatism is pragmatism
means doing what makes the most sense
what gives you the best
the least amount of work and unnecessary
effort within the framework of whatever
your personal moral code and standing is
pragmatists are not devoid of morals any
more than any other kind of person with
any other kind of approach or mental
processes is automatically devoid of
morals it really infuriates me this
assumption that pragmatists don't care
like yeah look maybe we don't care about
the rules because we don't get hung up
on the principle of the thing but that
doesn't mean we have no morals about the
end results or that nothing is
off-limits yeah sorry
kind of hit a button on that please tell
me you haven't read Frank Miller's Holy
Terror dear God no heck no I'm stealing
cars review on it that was entertaining
but no I would never read that what are
your thoughts on ben shapiro nothing i
would care to share in a public forum
and your opinion what Marvel character
or team is begging to become a movie how
would you go about making this movie if
you are given creative control I mean my
big design the thing is what I've been
hoping for is at least potentially
already happen or already happening
which what I really wanted was she-hulk
as basically superhero Ally McBeal as a
TV show and she Hoke is getting a TV
show we don't know enough in the details
to know if that's the angle they're
going for but I really hope so and it
would make the most sense because it
would control the cost of a weekly TV
show to have it be mostly courtroom set
and deal with her legal side of her life
so the thing I wanted most they might
even already be doing as far as a movie
like home no man like I like this kind
of font files under the same
of why I'm not great to ask hey who
would you cast Forex like I don't I
don't dream up the projects I want to
see I have opinions on the things that I
see are being done but I don't like
dream up oh if only because then I'm
left sitting here going oh but I don't
have it and then I'm upset about a thing
that doesn't even exist and I just don't
do that see gonna have to wrap it up in
a little bit slithers are freaking fine
guys come on I'm a Ravenclaw but I'll
stand for those who deserve it
appreciated have you read Harry Potter
on the methods of rationality nope have
not
Ouisa Lutheran's are brothers and
sisters we are together as one we will
do what is necessary oh god I just
started I just started a war didn't I so
there is in general they do have the
most bad seeds I mean in terms of the
narrative of the Harry Potter books
proper written from the perspective of a
Gryffindor who hates slytherins yes yes
they do
I mean I I guess I guess what annoys me
about the the denigration of Slytherin
see he may even not even be so much with
Rowling but the fact that people don't
take into account that the books are
from Harry's perspective like I know
it's not first-person restricted but
this is the only thought process we get
so it's a very biased account it's a
very narrowly focused account and it's
filtered through Harry's perceptions and
Harry doesn't like slow runs and so the
books don't like slytherins and people
take that as gospel it's not that's
Harry's perspective
Harry's human Harry's flawed Harry as a
Gryffindor is super judgmental just
sayin
have you seen the [ __ ] fight of Canary
Wharf no that's an interesting name
though do you ever feel like every real
human would be in Slytherin no no it
does feel to a certain degree like
lately dling that most of our
politicians would be in Slytherin and
that's not a good thing like no one
mentality approach should be completely
interpretive everything Slytherin or
anyone else so like that's its own set
of problems
should rollin be viewed like Lovecraft
loved try Lovecraft was extremely racist
that's sexist etcetera the stories
concepts he told we're mainly good
Rowling is not a good person but Harry
Potter is good I mean I don't know I
feel like I feel like the comparison to
Lovecraft is a bit harsh I mean like I'm
I'm very critical of JK Rowling
obviously but that's that feels like a
harsh comparison to me but I don't know
and look it you're getting into the
separate the artist from the art
argument and I have very complicated
feelings about all of that and given
that I'm trying to wrap it up for the
night I don't think I have time to try
and get into them
is that a no I want to ask you questions
about the culture universe when you've
only read one book in the series I don't
mind I mean as long as you are willing
to accept that any answer that I give
you is informed by only having read one
book as long as you accept that with my
answers don't mind let's see favorite
80s band um trying to think bands I like
that actually started in the eighties
there's bands that I like that did stuff
during the 80s but I like from the 70s
my queen is a set is a 70s band only
stones is a 60s band
60s and 70s you two started in the 80s I
haven't listened their stuff in a while
though I don't know how they're doing
these days their 80s stuff was really
good though
according to james rolfe the newest
episode of the Erie video game nerd is
going to be filmed in one continuous
shoot buggers stealing mine format I'll
sue now whatever you can do what he
wants favorite silent film hi it's been
a while since I've washed a silent movie
um no maybe the gold rush for JK has
been a lot of years since Harry Potter
and she lived a long time and rarefied
air it gets the point where you reach a
level of acclaim and start going off in
odd ways I mean like I don't want to I
don't want to pass too much judgement on
why or why not
Rowling is the way she gia says the
things that she says because I know her
personally like I'm not I'm not gonna
psychoanalyze somebody I don't know but
you know
ah any pet peeves that you have about
other youtubers um not really cuz
generally if I have pet peeves about a
YouTube where I stop watching them um
but I mean just like everybody use the
jump cut responsibly that's all I have
to say I think of Tiana from Princess
and the Frog
as a noble slithering because of her
ambition she's yeah she's a bit
Slytherin ish you know who's a Slytherin
anyone who watches sheera glimmer is a
slither love crabs who use would have
been close to mainstream when he was
writing no no no even for the time
Lovecraft was super racist even by the
standards of the age when he lived he
was super racist so if you're saying
that was the thoughts of the time know
like even by the metric of more racist
time he was still way over there
Robin Hood or Nightwing I mean I'm
probably gonna favor Robin Hood myself
I'm like yo there's a couple of classic
stories that I just enjoy I like singing
reinvented I haven't seen a good version
of in a while
hey just like Zorro I just like Robin
Hood I just like Treasure Island
I like Treasure Island a lot we haven't
gotten good versions of any of these in
a long time I wouldn't say we haven't
had a good version of a Zorro since the
first Antonio Banderas one that was the
90s we haven't had a good Robin Hood
film since Prince of Thieves yes Kevin
Costner was not great as Robin Hood but
it's still a good Robin Hood movie and
last good Treasure Island movie was
Treasure Planet so Shane I like these
stories and I like seeing them
reinvented hilda's season 2 set to
premiere possibly next September next
year dang it
that late turfs are way over there today
yeah yeah kinda yeah Lovecraft was out
there how do you think ruling will be
viewed years from now is an important
question though I is it though is the
question of how will she be you later
important to us now
I mean that question will matter at
later assessments of her and her work
after she's dead after we're probably
dead I guess do you mean Red Hood oh did
they say Red Hood see for some reason my
brain went Robin Hood cuz I don't like
Red Hood so there you go between red
hood and Nightwing is Knightly have you
ever seen Always Sunny yeah I don't like
the vibe on that no but anyway like I
there's something about having a hang-up
on
what will people think weh-weh leader
that just strikes me as an odd way to
view anything going on right now I mean
if you why if you're talking tangible it
yes that's important are we burning the
planet to the ground yes you should
probably fix that now but like just in
terms of artistic work and personal
views that aren't being used to shape
the behavior of others like through
politics or what have you I don't know
just thinking in terms of like what will
the future think of me just strikes me
as really odd because like how do you
even begin predicting what will be
considered normal in 20 years 30 years
40 50 100 and that just seems like
paralyzing to me just to even try and go
that way I love Zorba Treasure Island
Treasure Island's awesome I can't hear I
can't even like justify the line I just
I love that I love that story I love
that sense of adventure I love that
assemblage of weird characters I love
Treasure Island I think it's a I've read
the book I've seen a ton of different
adaptations of it I love it I should
rephrase reframes should we consider the
world at this time and how we've
progressed I mean I'm um I'm a
progressive by nature so I'm kind of
kind of always got my eye on where have
we come where do we have left to go
should she be viewed like that I mean I
don't know you know be careful the the
way in which you view others because you
may yourself be viewed that way
I don't know I can get on my high horse
but it's usually about fairly specific
things and fairly specific instances and
people I try not to broad-stroke it too
much unless there's something that like
I really just can't stand you know like
trans people aren't real so when it
comes to that yeah I'll get on the broad
strokes but you know um I'm always one
to beat the drum of context is
everything and part of my belief in that
means taking almost everything on a
case-by-case basis because the context
matters and if you're going to
acknowledge that the context matters
then you can't just make a broad
sweeping statement go and thus it is
forevermore in all cases that doesn't
work because whatever rule you make
there's exceptions and so I'd rather
just avoid the broad generalization in
the first place if I can it's not saying
I've never made them but you know I try
and be cautious of it I like lilo and
stitch but I think it's overrated I'm
actually gonna agree with you on that
I really should wrap up I'm going longer
than I intended to I'm more going on the
Lovecraft I'm sorry I'm gonna step up in
that conversation if you don't mind
would you ever make a video on anything
DD related probably not I'm not deep
into it or nothin there's way too many a
really good youtubers to talk about that
stuff I'm usually a case-by-case guy
schools turning me into a broad strokes
thinker
I have autism and talked to a lot of
people with disability you would not
believe the discrimination some of them
had faced um no I probably believe it
although I probably couldn't imagine it
accurately but if you tell me I probably
believe it I have some friends with
various disabilities both physical and
mental health that they you know work
through them they cope with but I you
know I do I do have a window into some
of that I obviously don't live with that
I have my own mental health thing I have
ADHD but like people don't know that
unless I tell them or they know me well
enough to maybe pick it up on their own
um but yeah yeah I am I would believe it
have a wonderful night and weakness
annual URL up Thank You Johnny yes I'm
actually gonna I'm gonna wrap it up
there so we what we went all over the
place as we tend to if you get the to
use the power of one infinity stone
which would it be and how would you use
it I'll probably the reality stone and
just mess with people for giggles but
thanks everybody for popping in
I do enjoy doing this and I appreciate
that the you folks work with me for the
fact that these go on kind of late
sometimes especially the ones that start
on the 9 p.m. Eastern Time ones but
thanks so much for joining me and just
remember folks you are beautiful
you're valid you are loved you are the
council I'm just around the meetings see
you